this is an archery bag it's not I can
shoot at something with my bow and arrow
take this yeah put it here up on
something eventually take this guy
it's my uncle's bow until he passed away
about 10 years ago
set my dad's garage for a little while
he gave it to me
now let me do some target practice we
want to shoot a Minecraft WWE video I
have an outline written and now the
question becomes what we should make the
costumes out of and how flexible and
durable this should be I think we should
make them on a crafty foam rather than
cardboard because in past experience has
shown us that cardboard like tends to
fall apart my concern with the foam like
we have this stuff yeah but it's pattern
on both sides it's gonna be a [ __ ] to
cut it's gonna take like four times more
time than cardboard this stuff is like -
it's too flimsy that's gonna just break
if any so cardboard it is all right
already
I want to be like shoot up after a movie
there
way I mean I'm not the bed I'm not let
me do any real shots of my crisis zone
right there I got to work on my shot for
a while
gotta warm up so right now I am going to
resume work on finishing up these
minecraft posting so I'm making three
zombies and I just have to paint them
and make the heads that's all I have
left on those guys I got my Steve
reference my John Cena skin some you
have to paint on the muscle pixels
that's a good reference for that these
are going to be zombie heads and then
for the Steve helmet I'm actually going
to reuse this Steve helmet because it's
all made I'm just going to give it a
nice fresh coat of paint glue it where
it needs to be glued where it's falling
apart this is super simple stuff it's
going to be a lot of painting today
we're going to hope I hope to like get
at least the base coats of all this
stuff painted by the end of the day what
are you doing here on a Saturday
Carmichael finishing tomorrow's vlog
such dedication to everyone's
entertainment every other day every
other day forever
hey the bullseye once did you Milo shots
are going right a little bit you get in
the glove though typhoon season we have
a good string release when you get her
teenagers maybe you gotta get better
fingers oh to a tip for kidding us
consistently drawl to the same point to
find a spot where you rest your hand on
your face draw that same spot every time
your arrow will shoot the same strength
every time
whoa today we're making arms oh yeah
that's like the best feeling cause
you've done - the fittings which is like
basically a needle run cords through
these legs you one cord here to keep it
like that one cord there and then you
attach these to a belt thing it's the
same thing for the zombies really the
bodies and legs are all they're all
assembled now I'm just doing arms this
is like the sleeve of the t-shirts and
the zombie arm and then after that I'm
going to finish the zombie heads so
there's this green paint dried way
darker than I'd anticipated but it's
okay because I'm probably going to end
up doing some pixel on the zombie head
so like use different shades of green to
create like a texture so I gotta say my
bill for his birthday last year I got a
bow we've all shot bow and arrow we've
all made plenty of videos with knights
and soldiers all kind of stuff so I'm
curious to see who in the office is
truly the best shot I'm gonna go make
coffee soon because I'm feeling that
feeling that 4 o'clock nap time blue
blues got some left on booze I just want
our students but I got a nap time